I want to give you a taste of how materials can be represented in a more
general way. You'll also learn a great term to impress your friends and
confound your enemies. Think about a surface and how it reflects light. The two
variables we use are the light's incoming direction and the amount of light
reflecting towards the eye. So at it's simplest, a material can be represented
by this function,given a light and eye direction, give back an intensity. This
function is called the BRDF which stands for Bidirectional Reflectance
Distribution Function. Let's look at that phrase. First, it's a function. The
inputs are the light and the eye. The function depends on two directions so
it's bidirectional. These directions are normally given with respect to the
surface itself, that is, each vector is often given as two numbers, the
altitude angle and the azimuth. The altitude is the angle away from the normal,
and the azimuth is the angle of the vector when projected onto the plain. The
phrase reflectance distribution means how the light is spread. One simple
example is a perfect mirror. The reflectance distribution in this case is that
when the eyes direction is exactly equal to the lights reflection direction,
all light is reflected towards the eye. Every other eye direction gets no
light. Another basic distribution is diffuse reflection. For some given
incoming light direction, the direction to the eye doesn't matter. That's the
definition of diffuse reflection. Since this value is constant, diffuse is then
represented by the surface of a hemisphere. Specular highlights are represented
by lobes. This distribution represents a glossy surface, where light is
reflected in a general direction. The lights direction determines where most of
the lights energy is reflected. If the load gets wider, the specular
reflections spreads out. Written this way, our BRDF needs four numbers, two for
the light and two for the eye. But if you think about it, most materials really
only need three. These two altitude angles and this azimuth between them. For
example if you put a sheet of paper on a table top and rotate it. Both the
light azimuth and eye azimuth angles change with respect to the paper, but the
angle between the two remains the same. Most materials are fine with three
numbers.